a rare pink manta ray was recently
spotted off the Great Barrier Reef and
at first it's almost too crazy to
believe but photo after photo shows that
this is the real thing and that this
Manta really is this pink his name is
inspector cluso he's an 11t male Reef
Manta and is the only known pink Manta
in the world at first scientists thought
inspectre Clo's color was the result of
a skin infection or Diet sort of like
how flamingos turned pink from eating
little shrimp but researchers took a
small skin biopsy from the Manta showing
this not to be the case instead they
think he has a condition called arism
like albino and melanistic animals
somewhere in his genome is probably a
mutation that makes his skin pigment
turn an abnormal color in this case pink
other animals can have this too but
seeing it in a manta is truly
extraordinary